So anyways,
Jacob gets away with this,
but Esau is not happy and,
and Jacob is quite convinced
that he might kill them.
And I think that was a reasonable fear
because he saw was a tough guy and he was
used to being outside and he knew how
to hunt and he knew how to kill and he
actually wasn't very happy about
getting seriously screwed over by his,
you know,
stay at home younger brother twice.
And so Jacob runs off and goes to
visit his uncle and on the way,
and this is a very
interesting part of the story,
he stops and to sleep and he takes a
stone for a pillow and then he has this
vision,
it's called a dream,
but the context makes it look like a
vision of a ladder reaching up to heaven
and with angels moving
up and down the ladder,
let's say.
And there are some
representations of that.
I showed you some of them
the last time we met,
but I'll read it to you first.
And he lighted upon a
certain place and tired.
They're all night because the sun was
set and he took of the stones of that
place and put them for his pillows
and laid down in that place to sleep.
And he dreamed and beheld a
ladder set up on the earth.
And the top of it reached to heaven.
And behold,
the angels of God ascending
and descending on it.
And behold,
the Lord stood above it and said,
I am the Lord God of Abraham,
thy father and the god of Isaac,
the land where on the Elias to the,
I will give it Nti seed.
And I see Chubby as the dust of the
earth and thou shalt spread abroad to the
west and to the east and
to the north and the south.
So that lays out the canonical directions,
right?
So now there's a center with
the canonical directions,
like the thing that you see,
you know,
that little symbol you see on maps,
it's the same thing that
symbolically placed upon the earth.
So a center has been
established with radiating,
uh,
well with,
with what?
With,
with direction lines radiating from it.
So it establishes as,
as a place
and in the young nice seed shall all
the families of the earth be blessed.
So that's pretty good news for Jacob
and it's not self evident why God is
rewarding him for running away
after screwing over his brother.
But that seems to be what happens.
And so here's a couple of representations,
classic representations.
Um,
the one on the right is William
Blake has when I particularly like,
you know,
and Blake assimilates God
with the sun when with light,
right?
So that's quite an common mythological
idea that that God is associated with
light and the day
will not leave thee
until I have done that,
which I have spoken to the and Jacob
awaked out of his sleep and he said,
surely the Lord is in this
place and I knew what not.
And he was afraid,
which is exactly the
right response and said,
how dreadful is this place?
It is none other than the house of
God and this is the gate of heaven.
And Jacob Rose up early in the morning
and took the stone that he had put for
his pillows and set it up for a pillar
and poured oil on the top of it.
And that's,
that's a more important
thing than you think.
And what,
we'll go into that a little bit more
deeply because up to this point in the
story,
there isn't anything really,
there isn't anything that's really
emerged to mark a sacred space,
right?
There's no,
there's no cathedral,
there's no church,
there's nothing like that.
But here's this idea that emerges that
you can mark the center of something
that,
and that's important.
Any market with a stone and a stone
is a good way to mark things that,
that are important because
the stone is permanent,
right?
And we mark things with stones now,
like we marked graves
with stones for example,
because we want to make a memory
and to carve something into stone,
to carve a stone and then to
carve something into stone
is to make a memory and
to use stone is to make a memory
because stone is permanent.
And to set it up right
is to indicate a center.
And so that's what happens in
pours oil on the top of it,
which is kind of offering,
and he called the name
of that place Bethel.
But the name of the city was
called [inaudible] at the first.
And Jacob vowed a vow saying,
if God will be with me and
we'll keep me in this way,
that I go and will give me bread
to eat and Raymond to put on.
Okay.
Then a 10th of what I earn,
I will give him.
I missed that.
That's interesting too,
because now there's a
transformation of sacrifice,
right?
Because until that point,
sacrifices have had
been pretty concretized.
It was the burning of something.
Whereas here,
all of a sudden it's the offering of,
of,
of productive labor per se,
like a tie,
because the tie,
there's a form of sacrifice.
And so there's an abstraction
of the idea of sacrifice,
sacrifice.
It's really important that the
idea of sacrifice gets abstracted,
right?
Because it should be abstracted
to the point where it's,
it's used the way that we use it today,
which is,
you know,
we make sacrifices to get ahead and
everyone understands what that means.
But the sacrifices are generally some
combination of psychological lend and,
and practical.
So we're not acting them out where it
precisely we're not dramatizing them or
ritualizing and we actually
act them out in our,
in the covenant that we
make with the future.
And we do that well.
Unless we're extraordinarily impulsive
and aimless in our lives and have really
no conception whatsoever of the future
and are likely to sacrifice the future
for the present,
which is what he saw does right?
Then we make sacrifices and you gotta
think like the idea of making sacrifices
to make the future better is an
extraordinarily difficult lesson to learn.
It took people,
God only knows how long to learn that,
you know,
like we,
we have no idea.
It's something that animals do easily.
Chimpanzees don't store leftover meat,
you know,
they just needed a wolf.
They just,
wolf can eat about 30 pounds
of meat in one setting.
And that's where the idea of
wolfing it down comes from.
They're not hiding it,
saving it for later.
You know,
they can't do that,
so they can't sacrifice
the present for the future.